stand by
for adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
with conventional fuel rockets it would
take 15 16 000 years to get to the
nearest star
conventional kind of rockets are just
out of the question for interstellar
travel you can have to do something a
little bit more out there
slow the harbin pulse when one half
impulse
what we're trying to do is build an
impulse engine like you here on star
trek we'd like it to go at about a point
for the velocity of light just so that
we can get to the nearest stars within a
human lifetime
there's no burnt up fuel there's nothing
being shot out of a tailpipe and it's
the gravitational field that actually
will propel this thing forward
this is the mac effect gravity assist
drive a device that could make
interstellar space travel possible
but the mega drive as it's known is also
a design that hinges on some pretty
controversial physics
for many years
you work on a project that people think
is nuts and you're likely to be regarded
as nuts too
now after 30 years of fine-tuning this
pair of scientists might finally be
close to getting the results they've
been hoping for
and nasa are taking the idea seriously
if something like that were true it'd be
earth-shaking i'd be it'd be
groundbreaking revolutionary new physics
but
those sorts of advancements don't come
along very often that would be a pretty
extraordinary claim to say that we've
we've put this new spin on the way the
universe works that we didn't know
before
it's a well-known newtonian law an
object at rest stays at rest and an
object in motion stays in motion at a
constant speed unless an external force
acts on it
all objects resist a push to some extent
and what makes them do that inertia
in the 19th century austrian physicist
ants mack made a conjecture that these
forces of inertia result from the
gravity of objects in the distant
universe
it became known as mac's principle and
while most experts have now dismissed it
scientists at this lab in california
think the idea is just misunderstood
mac's principle itself has sort of gone
out of vogue and people don't seriously
even discuss mac's principle anymore
it just depends on the way you think
about it
if you look in a textbook you might find
five or six different definitions of max
principle but the one i'm thinking of is
that distant matter
way out there can influence things up
close
to get your head around it take this old
analogy used to illustrate how mata
bends space-time
if you put a heavy object on a
trampoline it falls in and curves the
rubber sheet
now if you roll a ball on the trampoline
it will keep orbiting the heavy mass in
the center
that's how a planet behaves when it's
attracted by the gravity of a star
the thing is that for the rubber sheet
to act that way it has to be under
tension it has to be stretched and we're
saying that basically the distant matter
of the universe is what's pulling the
the space time and making it taut and
that's what's causing it to act like a
basically like a rubber sheet
the stretched rubber sheet is loaded
with potential energy and according to
the team's understanding of the mac
principle so is space-time
so we're thinking that there's a big
gravitational retention out there and
this device can actually tap into that
imagine the space time of the universe
as being like a very very flat lake and
you're sitting in a row boat the kind
that has the seat that moves backwards
and forwards but you don't have any oars
instead you have two great big buckets
like big trash cans
while you slide forward in the seat the
mass shifts around and the boat moves
slightly that's conservation of momentum
another newtonian law
if there are no external forces acting
on a system while it's moving its center
of mass has to stay in the same spot
and so the boat is moving to compensate
for the different distribution of mass
and what you're going to do is going to
dunk the buckets into the water which is
the universal space time and now you're
a lot heavier than you were
now you're going to slide back in the
seat and as you slide back the boat is
going to move under you so that your
center of mass remains in the same spot
the boat actually moves forward as you
slide back in the seat then you can dump
out the water if you don't need it
anymore and then you repeat that process
[Music]
the mega drive works in a similar way
the part which is doing all the work is
a stack of piezo electric crystals
the same kind of material that's in your
electric toothbrush
when you apply a certain frequency of
electric current the crystals expand and
contract which causes the whole device
to vibrate
but the mega drive is set up to vibrate
mainly in one direction which causes it
to accelerate slightly
the team says this acceleration enables
the device to tap into the gravitational
potential of the universe by borrowing
some of its energy the crystals change
mass and the device starts behaving like
our rowboat
that mass changes what's causing the
proportion because each crystal kind of
moves in this sort of fashion so the
whole stack is in this breathing mode
which moves backwards and forwards as it
gains energy it increases mass and then
it shrinks again and loses mass if you
time it just right
you can actually make that thing move
forward
all of this has been the life's work of
jim woodward who set off on this path
over three decades ago
since then he's been working alone on
the mega drive project in his spare time
until his desk at the university was
relocated to the office of hal fern
i was away on sabbatical and i came back
and there he was so there i was
and hell was not happy
and at first i thought it was absolutely
insane what on earth is this guy trying
to do i took a closer look at what he
was doing that's when i really became
more interested the shift is very small
though
i grew up on star trek and i would love
to be able to say that i worked on
something that would help people get
across spacetime quickly
if the theory turns out to be correct
and we aren't really tapping into the
gravitational field it would be a
serious breakthrough it's just i've got
to prove it
[Music]
but proving this idea has been a problem
the movements of the device have been
extremely small not large enough to
register with the naked eye
but after receiving two grants from the
nasa institute for advanced concepts or
niacc for short the team has managed to
greatly improve their existing prototype
jim was basically paying all this out of
his own money he must have put 30 to 50
000 into this project he didn't want to
buy off the shelf kind of equipment uh
because some of it wasn't available when
he started doing this 30 odd years ago
you couldn't buy some of the equipment
you just had to make it and build the
circuits yourself
we did have some people come over at one
point and they saw jim's
homemade boxes didn't really take him to
that seriously i had to convince jim to
buy some equipment to know off the shelf
that we could get fully calibrated
trying to get things set up so that we
could
actually do some runs that would
make interesting video material
many new collaborators have joined along
the way and the team has designed a new
setup for the device
hanging it from a pendulum to increase
thrust and eliminate any vibrations
which might be mistaken for it
okay here we go
three two
one
they finally started seeing it move with
their own eyes
you can physically see the things
shudder around vibrating and you can
physically see it move off to one side
so that's actually quite exciting if we
can actually show that by video then i
think that should took convince quite a
few people it's on a reflector on the
frame
okay
i still think we should give jim that
that that ear horn that looks like a
wormhole no
something looks cool
yeah
the devices we build now produce those
type of forces between a hundred and a
thousand times
larger than the forces that we were
producing even a year or two ago
it's it's very very small if you think
of maybe a little pulley with a with
little mass
on the end of a string the force that
that will produce if you drop say two or
three grams of weight down you'd almost
barely feel it in your hand it's almost
like the weight of a feather maybe a
little bit more than the feather maybe
two feathers i'll be generous i'll give
you a couple of feathers
the team calculates that the smaller the
device the larger the force it can
generate so instead of scaling up they
hope that a raise of thousands of tiny
mega drives powered by a nuclear battery
could one day be deployed to accelerate
large probes into interstellar space
they are sufficient actually in and of
themselves
to make it possible to
take a starship a human crude starship
to nearby stars and back in some
reasonable fraction of a human lifetime
so the question is have we all screwed
up are we collectively smoking something
do we not know what we're doing
i suppose you might argue that that's
the case but the way to find out is to
find out whether or not the gizmos that
we make are really doing what we say
they are doing
a few other teams have already tried to
replicate the mega drive's results but
the findings were negative
people don't expect this thing to work
it sounds so bizarre there are several
things that could happen that could
cause these false positives and that's
what people think is going to happen if
they're saying this this strange effect
is actually real then um
and then somebody somebody else comes
along and proves it wrong then they they
look like they have egg on their face
basically so it's much harder to say
that something is is a real effect when
it's
when it's controversial
because of this controversy nasa is now
funding an independent study of the mega
drive at the naval research laboratory
the neat thing about the claim here is
they say there's some revolutionary new
physics that lets you vary your inertial
mass which means you can actually be
heavier and lighter at different times
and if you can wiggle at the same time
as you're changing your mass now you've
maybe got a way to move yourself around
and do some sort of wiggly wiggly wiggly
thing
all through space
now is that possible in this universe
maybe maybe not
mike mcdonald is part of a team testing
the device but even he admits that
conclusively proving or disproving this
theory won't be easy
is the test going to be conclusive let
me answer that question with a question
what if i ask you to prove to me that
there are no pink elephants
now you might say every elephant i've
ever seen is gray
but how do i know you just haven't
looked hard enough the answer is that
you can't really prove a negative
tests give us enough information to
decide if the way we think the world
works is valid enough for us to keep
going in that direction and that's what
this sort of test can tell us
if you ask me to put on my you know my
betting hat and say are we are we really
going to see exactly the effect that is
claimed and is it going to be
so strong that we think ah yes it's
definitely the mechanism that's claimed
too
you know i'd say that's
that's a number probably somewhere
between 1 and 10 and 1 in 10 million and
i would lean toward the higher end the
odds the odds are on no to be honest but
the odds are on no for every new idea
that comes up and remember that science
isn't a tool that gets dirtied by use
you know the scientific method comes out
of any encounter looking as shiny as
where it started
and if we use it well
even if we don't find that there's some
new effect here we'll learn something
about how to do these kinds of tests
better in the future for whatever is
coming along next
there's a small but real chance that
there's nothing to it
for me it's exceedingly unlikely
but there's been more than one occasion
where things haven't gone right on a
particular day
and i've started drafting an apology to
the people who are interested in this
saying gee guys i'm really sorry
you know it wasn't real after all
i haven't had one of those episodes in a
number of months
[Music]
assuming the device passes its
replication trials and nothing else can
explain the forces the team is claiming
one day the ultimate test would be for
an array of mega drives to maneuver a
cubesat in space
i'm 79 years old so i don't know how
long i'm going to live
a few years maybe i'll see something in
space maybe i won't if i live longer
than that i'm pretty sure i will see
something in space
science fiction will be vindicated as
transformed into scientific fact in that
regard
[Music]
you